Kota is a week ago today you were
talking to you breeze and you just had a
moment I also think a lot of things are
contagious including generosity so our
hope is is that because you know you let
us know that you made this big generous
donation I think other people look and
say hey maybe I can help out too drew we
love you love you too okay thank you
alright a lot more watching over and
over I loved your reaction was so
genuine what was going through your mind
at that moment I think everybody has
like their breaking point somewhere
sometimes you have it the bathroom at
home where you're in the car and your
kids are inside I mean mine probably was
at the least appropriate place it could
have been but I think there was
something about his kindness and his
generosity in that moment and I think
when he said like as a big strong
football player when I said I love you
drew cuz I just say that usually and he
was like I love you and I just something
about all of it just kind of you came
together and I feel like we're all on
the hairy edge like you know and I think
he you know we all need to pick a place
I wish it hadn't been this place but I
think we all have to have a place where
we can like let the dam break wherever
that place happens to be I thought in
that moment that the I love you got you
because of your relationship now that
you two have that kind of special
relationship well he's he may be like
one of the most perfect human beings
because he's an awesome father and
husband he's a great friend to people he
loves his team he's a great leader and
he loves his city the city of New
Orleans which I love too I have a
fortune to have a special connection
with Drew and but but seeing his
generosity just eclipses everything like
the guy is in a class all by himself
yeah I agree now savanna how hard was it
for you because you're not sitting next
to Jota but you understand you somehow
need to comfort your friend at that
moment I know it's a lot but I'm so
sorry hunch take them sorry
it's a lot I know where your heart is my
dear
I do how about I read the tease okay
okay deep breath I could just understand
exactly where she was coming from I
think it's because the tender word that
Drew had for her to say I love Donna you
know I know that really touched her but
also I thought because she cares so
deeply for the people of New Orleans and
not a whole interview was about really
about what they're going through and
their suffering and that's why such a
high know where your heart is Hoda I
know what you're thinking I know why it
hurts because you're thinking of these
people who've been through so much and
why again and you know I'm actually I'm
so proud of Hoda every day I think she's
incredible on multiple levels but I was
really proud of her in that moment
especially because she opened the way
for a lot of people to say you know
we're all so blessed and lucky if it
hasn't touched us personally yet but
that doesn't mean that is a time of
uncertainty and sadness anxiety and it's
okay to feel your feelings and it's okay
to let it out some kind and it's okay to
do that and then take a breath and then
smile and move on what she does better
than anybody else so I think she's just
showing her heart and the reason why
everyone loves her and can I just say
one thing this taught me something else
Savannah like you weren't with me but
you were and I never thought a person
could be comforted like but you know
like by FaceTime or across the screen I
just didn't think that was possible even
but I found out it was like you're like
I can feel you it makes you emotional
every time you watch it it reminds us
that you all are genuine folks and
speaking of that emotion Savannah I'll
ask you first what is it like because
you have to tell tough stories each and
every day and bring tough news to people
out there
it isn't easy it is not easy
right now I mean we know how lucky we
are and we're we're lucky because we
have each other we have our families we
still have our jobs and we have a
purpose and I think both holding our own
everybody on the Today Show staff who's
working so hard feel really strongly
about that but it's hard to tell these
stories and I know why people say it's
enough I don't want to hear it anymore I
get it I feel the same way it's going to
ask the questions it's hard sometimes to
ask the hard questions you know I don't
want to get in confrontation or fight
but I feel like right now we got to be
on the side of information in fact I
really want to get those facts for our
viewers like I just like I'm gonna find
out for you guys I'm gonna do it and we
all feel that way you know is it's a
tough time yeah hold up up for you
I was just listening to Savannah and I
think there's nobody better really at
like um getting to the nut of it like
getting the detail and understanding and
not just being okay with broad-brush
statements like getting to it because if
I were at home listening I would want to
know how I can keep my family safe I
need specifics I don't need broad brush
things and I think I think Savannah has
a has a really really great way of
getting to it I always learned something
after one of her interviews and if
there's ever a time when we need it it's
now like this is the time when you need
that to get facts and information out
and I think we try on our show to do
that in the best way and while we're
doing it we're really mindful of our of
our tone we want you to know that you
know we're holding your hand virtually
as we're telling you what's going on and
I think that's probably the best way we
can do it
[Music]